- Where's Maestro?
- He's probably still arranging some sort of surprise for us.
- What a marvel, what a find, what a rare object.
Ho, ho, ho, ho, yes, indeed.
This time, I was lucky.
- What is it?
What is it?
- You'll never guess.
Even if you see it, go ahead, unwrap it.
You'll see.
Never guess.
- What?
- All right, guess.
What is it?
Take a good look.
You gotta guess first.
No, it's a lot more like a water pump.
Anyway, turns around, it's an electricity generator.
No, no, no, not at all.
Come closer now and listen very, very carefully to it.
It's a prehistoric Walkman.
A phonograph, is that it?
Yes, you're right.
Better still, this is the very first phonograph.
The voice you're going to hear was recorded more than a century ago in 1878.
Turn the crank as you sing.
Old-fashioned gadget.
Yeah, piece of junk, you gotta hear it.
Eh, it isn't this.
You're busting our eardrums.
Is that right? Recorded a century ago?
Mm-hmm.
Well, who was it that invented the phonograph?
Thomas Edison, an American.
And without exaggerating,
you know I never exaggerate, not me.
Without exaggerating, he was the greatest inventor of all time
with hundreds of inventions.
You mean it? The greatest ever?
Yes, because he did begin very young.
He had so many ideas, even when he was just a small child.
It was very clear he had an insatiable curiosity.
Mom, why does a goose sit on her eggs?
To keep them warm.
Then why should they stay warm?
So they'll hatch.
What do you mean, hatch?
It means the little chicks come out of their eggs.
They come out because the egg is hot?
Oh, yes.
You are full of questions, Tom.
Uh-oh.
Where is Thomas?
He's out in the barn, I guess.
Thomas, where are you? Dinner is ready.
Finish what?
I see the chicks come out.
Tom, it takes many days for eggs to hatch.
Come and have dinner.
Or else your father will be angry.
Mr. Meg.
Keepers and the Christmasmen are leaving the town.
Port Huron, Canadian border.
It's a continuous line to Canada, it's a good sign.
Must practice learning your lessons by heart.
Excellent for the memory.
Let's go.
Two times two.
Two times three.
Six.
Four.
What do you say?
Excuse me, but just made...
School, you're good for nothing, you're dumb.
Nothing in life.
Say nothing, just get out.
Son is an imbecile.
Believe me, I know.
You are the imbecile, and I will prove it, Mr. Teacher.
Listen, Tom, that teacher is really stupid.
I'll teach you my way.
Well, how's it going, Tom?
He was no dope.
Newton, I understand gravitation, the solar system,
but the calculations are too hard.
Chemistry, now that's interesting.
I think I'll experiment a little.
Be careful, Tom. It could be very dangerous.
No, it won't.
No trouble. It's okay.
I don't want any more of your junk around.
The cellar is full of bubbles, retorts, acids.
There's no room to walk.
You clean the cellar, understand?
I saw one in the sky once flying.
How'd it fly?
Filled up with hydrogen.
It's a gas that's much lighter than air.
Lighter than air? It's crazy.
Wanna try it?
Sure.
You see this powder?
When you add water, it gives off hydrogen.
I'll show you.
Take some powder and drink some water
and you'll get lighter and fly.
You'll sure?
Can't ever be sure.
To experiment, scared?
Oh, me.
Are you lighter?
Either, I think.
Try jumping to be sure.
Doesn't work.
I know why.
Why?
Cause your stomach's too small.
Big does it have to be?
be great having a telegraph between our houses you really think it'll work sure
finally here did you want to tell me well mom no I'm almost grown up I want a
job but what sort of job Tom selling papers on the train Thomas ten cents
ten cents just say mama can't you hear anymore - well was an accident on the
train 1861 the war between the states was ripping the country in two it's the
battle that'll decide the war general grant against general johnson i know that i can sell a thousand
copies of your newspaper thousand sell that yes i have an idea for any that i don't sell i will pay
ha ha wasn't on tom edison's account i'll be right back please send this message to all the stations
from here to port huron say that news is arriving on the greatest of the war the newspaper's on the
way huh yeah if i do what am i gonna get out of it a subscription to the paper a year subscription
free yeah okay i'll send it sense read all about it yeah i'll take this battle ever read all any
cents of the great battle 25 cents here mom a hundred dollars for you here mom this is for you
ha ha ha age of 15 edison starts printing his own paper in the train teach you there's no point in
going so fast if you make mistakes again slowly thomas you're talented very good 40 words a minute
That's it. You're a real telegraphist now. Your parents should be proud of you.
Mom, they hired me as a telegraph operator in town.
It's urgent, Tom. It's very urgent. This message has to be sent to Sarnia on the Canadian side.
Ice has brought the lines down. It can't be sent. I'm sorry.
It's terribly urgent.
I have an idea.
Huh? What's that, huh?
Megasdale, sending a message. Quickly. Bring me a locomotive. Apply to the message.
Here's your reply, sir.
Brilliant idea. A genius.
Listen, where is that message?
Oh, I wasn't paying attention.
You are fired.
Have an idea.
Well, me, sir, the rats.
The next few years, Edison travels from one job to another, not settling down anywhere from city to city.
Legerfus, do you have a job for me?
Is your speed?
Forty words a minute.
Oh, see that.
You're hired.
You'll work with Adams here.
It's me, Adams.
You coming?
It's time we were at work.
Hey, what are you doing with all that, huh?
Well, I'm really interested in doing experiments.
Electricity, chemistry, everything, you understand?
Right now, I'm doing tests on experiments carried out by a Swedish chemist, Alfred Nobel.
But I think I'll stop.
Could be a little dangerous.
What exactly is it?
Oh, it's a mixture of nitroglycerin and a paste with other things.
Nobel calls it dynamite.
What's this?
A multiplex.
Oh, what does it do?
Well, you can transmit several messages over the same line.
Watch it, Adams.
Don't touch it.
Pull the wires. You'll be electrocuted.
It's acid.
Wash it off.
You're not a pretty sight. You should be more careful.
That? It's a machine for counting ballots.
I'm going to present it to Congress in Washington and I'll get rich.
Hmm...
I'll explain, Senator.
This machine automatically counts votes.
You'll gain an enormous amount of time.
We're going to save time, my boy.
You ought to know we don't want to save time.
We want to save our seats in Congress.
Let me just explain it. It's really simple.
Then you can decide for yourself whether or not my invention is useful.
A few more unsuccessful attempts.
And at 22, he was up to his ears in debts.
Edison had lost everything.
The Civil War was over.
And for the United States, the period was extraordinary.
And New York became a financial center with its first skyscraper and a steam-driven elevator.
The railroad links the Atlantic and the Pacific.
Baseball becomes a national sport, and roller skating was very fashionable.
One dollar, the last one.
Well, it won't take me very far.
Not in coffee.
How much?
That'll be 10 cents for you, son, the house.
The machine doesn't work. It's useless.
That's a piece of junk.
But it's your fault, Lars.
You're a nincompoop, Pope.
If we can't send messages, I'm ruined.
Pardon me, gentlemen.
What?
I'm pretty sure that I can repair your broken machine.
You understand them?
Yes, in a way.
Come on.
Yes, I can repair it.
Leave me alone for a moment.
It's all right. The young man inspires confidence.
Machine is working now.
You're hired, young man. $300 per month.
Will that do?
Oh, yes.
Well, it's a beginning.
Mr. Edison, I'll buy your machine.
Five thousand dollars.
All right.
Mr. Edison, Western Union is interested in your synchronization system.
How much?
I'm waiting to hear your offer.
I would like four thousand.
I would take three.
Let's say, um, would you take forty thousand?
Yes, I would.
Mr. Edison will buy your patent for the multiplex telegraph.
What is your price?
$25,000, Mr. Orton.
Deal.
Plus the annual fees, of course.
Of course, Mr. Edison.
I'll take the entire floor.
The fact is I need offices as well as workshops and a production area.
Hmm.
Scared me.
I scared you? You mean it? I really did?
Not really.
I hope not, because I want to marry you.
Listen.
What are you doing here today?
You can see I'm trying to repair this machine.
Gotten what day it is?
What?
For a start, it's Christmas.
What's more, you just got married.
Good Lord.
But we simply must pay our taxes or we'll have a terrible fine as well.
You're right. I'll pay him, yes.
Please, go now.
Huh?
A daydream, are you?
My name is, uh...
Oh, never mind.
Next.
And before long, he had set up what is the very first research and development laboratory anywhere in Menlo Park, New Jersey.
Here, Fred, put your hand out.
The needles.
That's right. It's sound vibrations.
I'm certain they can be recorded and then reproduced.
This cylinder is covered with a very soft metal.
When I turn it, the needle cuts a continuous groove.
My voice is recorded.
Now, listen carefully.
I'll turn it.
Yes, I know.
It still requires a lot of work.
Meanwhile, I'm working on another project.
Now, this thread is carbonized.
It can be heated by electricity and not burn.
We'll put it into a glass globe in a vacuum.
You'll see.
One day, everybody will use this illumination.
Clean and it's bright.
Full steam ahead.
To light up a whole city, we'll need a more powerful dynamo.
I'd better work on it.
Faraday demonstrated that movement could be used to produce electricity, and electricity produced movement.
And so, I can make a train run on electricity.
With my giant dynamo, I can light whole sectors.
It's incredible.
For the first time in history, a whole sector of a city would have electric lighting.
Yeah, but hold on. That's not all. You'll see. There's also...
Yes, hello?
No, ma'am. I am not the butcher on the corner.
No, I don't have spare ribs. In fact, I'm fat.
Did Edison also invent the telephone, too?
You know, Alexander Graham Bell and Alicia Gray invented that.
But he added things, and in the end, his system was adopted.
But just wait, there's more yet.
Madam Mary Rose, I perfected my phonograph.
I believe that now it is equal to the beauty of your voice.
To Edison, what an...
No crank for me to turn?
No, a spring motor drives the phonograph all by itself now.
Do I sing?
If you please.
How are we doing, Dixon?
It works. Look at this.
Of course, there's still work to do.
You see, the platform turns, and so it always faces the sun.
You see?
Mm-hmm.
Ready for you, Miss Mary Rose.
And two Frenchmen a few years later,
Louis and Auguste Lumiere would perfect the cinema camera,
but it's Edison who invented it.
Perhaps Edison wasn't really a great scientist.
More of an inventor, you might say.
Literally, he is the one who ushered in the modern era of communications,
and we can thank him for many of the wonderful devices
that we use in our everyday lives today.
It's in part thanks to Edison that I'm here with you all today, children, telling his story.